There is a stunning new poll from right wing
Fox news showing that that
more than half of Americans want Donald Trump,
not just impeached, but impeached and removed
from office.
Now.
Earlier this week I told you about the new
Washington post poll and that one said 60%
of the country agrees with the impeachment
inquiry and that support for the inquiry has
tripled among Republicans from about 10% to
about 30% the Fox news poll asked something
else which is do you believe that Donald Trump
should be impeached and removed and 51% of
Americans now say yes, he should an additional
4% say yes on impeachment but not yet sure
on the removal.
This poll being from Fox news will likely
accelerate Donald Trump's breakup with Fox
news, which we've been tracking for a long
time.
That's really kind of a sad store, a side
story, but there is one interesting thing
to mention there.
Remember how last week I told you that former
Republican speaker of the house, Paul Ryan
is now a board member at Fox news.
There is speculation.
People are saying as Donald Trump likes to
say, there is speculation that it is Paul
Ryan's disgust with Donald Trump.
That may actually be behind some of the separation
that we're seeing between Fox and Trump recently,
which is an interesting theory, but a story
for another day.
Back to the polling, truly devastating numbers,
and I want to talk about why and I really
want you to understand the significance of
these numbers.
I went back and looked at polling from the
1970s Gallop was doing a lot of polling of
the Nixon white house in the 1970s this was
when the water date's scandal was ramping
up for Richard Nixon and the portion of the
country that wanted Nixon impeached remained
quite low, well into the impeachment inquiry
even when the majority of the country already
believed Watergate is serious.
Already believed that Nixon was guilty of
wrongdoing in that only 26% of the country
believed that Richard Nixon should be impeached
and removed and Nixon remember, didn't have
the benefit of a right wing media echo chamber
defending everything that he does all the
time.
This thing started two weeks ago and more
than half of the country now believes that
the president should be removed from office
in a Fox news poll.
Now there's another interesting thing for
most presidents.
You gauge how things are going by approval
rating.
Trump's approval rating has become completely
secondary.
We are now gauging how things are going by
how many people want Donald Trump impeached
and removed.
This is not normal.
The fact that the focus now is not on approval,
but on impeachment support means that things
are are very different from the way they normally
are with American presidents.
This is also, by the way, new territory for
Trump in that in business, when he's gotten
into trouble, he has the escape hatch of bankruptcy
and he's used it.
He's pulled, he's pulled the cord on that
escape hatch.
Many times you can't declare bankruptcy from
what's going on right now.
I guess the equivalent would be resignation,
but we're very, very far from that really
being a discussion.
So that being said, a refusal to cooperate
with the impeachment inquiry makes him look
more guilty to normal people.
His followers will resist that.
They'll say, no, no, he's doing the right
thing.
It's a witch hunt.
He's fighting it.
He's not going to bow down to the witch hunt.
But even some Republicans are going to see
Trump's refusal to cooperate at all as a sign
of guilt.
Nixon tried to fight impeachment.
He lost.
Trump, thinks he can fight it, and when he
may be right, a buddy may not.
Now let me throw something else at you.
About the 51% wanting Donald Trump impeached
and removed.
Trump lost the popular vote.
Okay.
By a lot, by more than any previous president,
millions of votes.
This is now being called a coup attempt by
defenders of Trump.
And by Trump himself.
This is a cue to reverse the election results
and remove Donald Trump from office by the
very people who never voted for him in the
first place.
I went back and looked, every impeachment
in history was called a coup attempt by the
defenders of the president that was at risk
of being removed.
So that is another propaganda technique made
to once again, uh, distract from the fact.
And I encourage you not to fall for it.
This is a constitutionally enshrined mechanism
to investigate and adjudicate the wrongdoing
of a precedent.
It is not a coup.
It's almost the opposite and it is not a new
thing.
Every president facing impeachment has had
defenders say, this is an attempt at a coup.
It is not.
This is how the system is designed.